I'm sorry for making guys all wake guys.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god.
I just got home I went home and I'll fucking rush straight
here.
Oh, give me a sec.
Okay.
Do not judge me.
I know you guys judge me about all the other stuff.
Do not.
I will not tell you guys what it, okay, guys, you guys need
to promise me.
I'm really sorry.
I really appreciate everybody for waiting so long.
I've been all over the place.
All right.
So, um, so do not judge me or I won't tell you what it is.
Do you want story time or not?
That's why I'm holding story time hostage.
I'm holding story time hostage until you say you won't judge
me.
If you judge me, I won't tell you the story.
I need you to, we all have to be here together and we all
gotta agree that you will not judge me.
No, I have another story.
If you guys judge me, I won't tell the story.
I need five people in a row.
say it, I won't judge you.
If I see someone say, I'll judge you.
I won't tell you.
So if I see five people in a row, different people, you
can't spam it and trick me.
Say it, I won't judge you.
I'll tell you the story.
If you continue to judge me, we won't get story time.
We'll go straight to the game.
And then be like, that's what we wanted, Doki.
We wanted you to play the game.
We wanted you finally to finish.
Get the first ending of Armory Court.
That's all we, but, but don't you guys And then make you
stay up even longer for me to get the first ending of Armor
Core?
We listen and we won't judge.
Oh, already.
We'll perhaps judge you.
I won't judge you, maybe.
Hell, no judge at all.
Sorry, please.
We never judge your most normal bird.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, the Super Chat, Jared.
Thank you, thank you.
Cass, thank you, the Super Chat.
I need all of us to be in agreement.
that you will not judge me.
I won't judge you.
I promise.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Skip, I have work in the morning.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
So, I'm not eating at all today.
That's the end.
That's the end of the story.
I...
That might be the end of the story.
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me order food right now.
Let me order...
Let me...
Let me order food right now.
So I did have a little snack, though.
I did have a little snack.
A little bake.
I would judge you, but say it anyway.
Ninja, thank you for the magenta soup.
I've been running off pure adrenaline, by the way.
I've been running off pure adrenaline I did have a snack I
had a little um a little pastry in between like during this
entire run I felt like I was doing a run right now like
first first run well thank you thank you thank you 55
hamburgers um don't worry dad's a dog sitter dad is getting
the fucking uh pamp the spoiled life right now I tell you
guys this I got a text from my dog sitter uh yesterday I
don't know if I told you guys this because I you know a lot
of stuff was going on.
Like, like I said, I'm trying to fit as much stuff as I can
for you guys and also for me before I go on a vacation
because I will be traveling for the vacation.
So I'm trying to buy as much stuff as I like get like my
checklist.
By the way, I don't need my checklist.
By the way, I did not buy the shoes, by the way.
If you were not watching, I did not buy the shoes.
I got distracted.
You would understand.
I'll tell you guys the story.
The moment I finished talking about ordering food.
Anyway, yesterday I got a text message from my dog sitter
and Because I was like, how's Jokey doing?
How's Dad doing?
And then my dog sitter was like, he's doing great.
He's commanding a bit more attention this day.
As in, aka, I think that's like polite speak from my dog
sitter being like, it's being like a fucking bitch right
now.
I think that's my dog sitter trying to tell me that my dog
is being a fucking brat.
Fucking little bitch boy.
And I was just like, yeah, he's been a bit more bratty and
needy the last week.
So like trying to apply, it's not my fault.
It was a recent development.
Mm-hmm.
It was, I don't know what's going on.
I don't know what's going on.
It's just been happening very recently, as in like the last
couple of years.
But very recently, as in this week.
I know, not sure what triggered it.
sure that's what i wrote back i literally wrote yeah he's
been a bit more bratty and needy last week not sure what
triggered it couldn't be me yep very recently just very
recent behavior that he has learned like literally just last
week uh it was so spontaneous oh my gosh well i don't know
where it came from uh um patria said thank you with super
chatty thank you over to the fire McDonald's being the only
super chat thank you thank you simple the even super chat
thank you thank you the question is kind of hard to answer
because we don't know the story dokey tell us then we'll see
if we need to judge me with super chat thank you thank you
um anyway the uh she also sent me a video of this wait let
me see if i can play it let me play it that's him
That's my dog.
That's my dog, by the way.
He's enjoying it.
No, he's playing right now.
He's playing with...
Why does he sound like that?
I'm just letting you listen to the sound.
He's, like, playing right now.
He's...
What is wrong?
Yeah, he's playing.
That's his...
That's him nominating.
on a toy all right let me order food i'm not eating anything
at all before like i was gonna order i was gonna eat before
stream but then i woke like the more afternoon stream i was
gonna eat the afternoon stream but then i got obviously you
know i woke up a little too late for that and i was gonna uh
eat food after stream but that's i had to get everything
done within the period between the two streams so now i
didn't eat i got a snack i got like a bakery good like a big
pastry uh during um also but i did got like um i did got a
drink though and then and by time i finally and then it was
a little bit of a traffic jam so i was like stuck in traffic
for like 45 minutes and then i got home and i started stream
why does it sound like a 50 year old man stowing after three
years but you have to think it was a super chat thank you
thank you all right i'm gonna try and figure out what i want
to eat for dinner right now i don't know if i want i want to
eat anything like i don't know, I want, I don't, I don't
want to get, I don't know what to get.
Uh, yeah, so I was in a little bit of a traffic jam.
Anyway, I did not buy the shoes.
If you were here for the afternoon stream and I was saying
that I would need it to get shoes, um, I did not buy shoes.
Um, instead, I came back.
Well, I bought a lot of other stuff.
I bought like more clothes.
I bought, uh, some trinkets.
I bought some custom nails, um, that were like 50, they were
like 60 plus Canadian dollars per nail set but they were
like customized designs I can't show it because then they'll
like docks uh because it's like a local it's like a local
creator um uh in my city so I can't show it like she's like
a local artist um in my city in my city so I can't show it
uh but they're really cute it's like those like actual like
hand custom made custom nails that's why it was that It was
like 60 plus Canadian dollars And it was really, I can't
even tell you guys what it was I just say they were really,
really cute Anyway, but And also, do not judge Do not judge
It happens to everybody, guys Like, it happens to everyone
But I also bought three Minion dendroids Of Bob Stewart and
Kevin
Look, you know You don't understand, Bob wears a crown.
So I can display it next to my Bob's Waski crystal.
Look, this is what they look like.
Okay, the boxes are really cute.
Anyway, so I didn't take a picture of the box.
I just put everything on the floor after I got home and
rushed to the PC.
But, um, look at this.
let me grab a picture for you guys so you can see in your
head you don't have to like imagine it um so i bought all
three of these i i bought all three of these nendrods and
like you can have multiple accessories so like there's
here's uh um here's here they are where bob has a bob has a
little crown so this is what they look like uh the minions
nendroid and i got all three of them so it's a full it's not
by the way you have to buy them separately so it's not like
they come in a three pack i bought all three so it didn't
come in a three pack it's individual so i bought all three
of Bob has a, Bob has a crown and three independent
decisions that I made.
And then here's what Kevin's box looks like.
Let me show you guys.
There's Bob.
And here's, uh, here's Stuart.
Sorry, Stuart.
This is Stuart.
And then, and then here.
where's kevin where's kevin's box
okay kevin um and then here's what kevin looks like and then
this is kevin so um i came i might not have come home with
shoes but i came home with three wonderful minion I came
home with three wonderful minion dendroids
from my from my shopping adventures yay um girl buy some
damage shoes cyber think it was super chat thank you thank
you solid you think it was super chat thank you thank You
make it really hard to not judge Doki.
I won't because that be me with Doki merch, but it's not
easy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Next, see you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
At this point, I'm scared a Doki minion skin suit is
inevitable.
See you next Halloween, guys.
Wonder what's going to happen on Halloween.
No!
Spoilers!
Alright guys, let me order food real quick.
I actually should eat.
The smart thing I should do is actually eat, so let me... I
don't know what... The thing is, I just don't know what to
get.
Yeah.
Do I have jolly bees?
I'm a jolly bees.
If I don't know what I want to eat, I always get jolly bees.
I'm just a jolly bee gal um i just love jolly bees what can
i say i don't know the i just love the pasta i love the
jolly bees pasta um i recommend jolly bees to my friend and
then they were like it's mediocre and i was like how dare
you i was just like i can't be your friend anymore i i
cannot be your friend i'm sorry but i gotta cut you out
you're too toxic in this friendship
I love the sweet spaghetti.
I love it so much.
It's like every time, every time I'm like, I don't know what
to eat.
I always just get Jolly Beats because I just love that.
It's not even the chicken.
I don't care about the chicken.
It's literally just, it's literally just the spaghetti.
It's so good.
What's the palette box?
I don't know what the palette box.
I don't look at anything else.
Like my eyes are for the spaghetti only.
I have eyes for one thing and one thing only.
What is that?
Let me check.
I can literally just scroll down and see what it is.
I mean, I could try it.
I only ate one meal.
If they have it, I'll give it a shot.
Oh, what is that?
Traditional covered in garlic sauce?
Oh, they have a burger.
I've never had the burger steak either.
I don't know what that is.
What's Pada Bac?
What kind of... Is this like...
Cajun Filipino noodle dish?
You know what?
Fuck it.
I'll give it a shot.
I never tried the burger steak either.
Um...
You know what?
I'm ordering it too.
Fuck it.
I order...
All the pastas.
I'll get rid of this.
I want the pineapple quencher.
And I'll grab that in.
I haven't tried it so.
I mean, I've only had one meal anyway.
So, I mean, I have not, sorry, not even one meal.
I haven't eaten anything at all today.
I think I was legitimately just running off adrenaline.
Not going to lie.
It was just pure adrenaline going through every place,
everywhere.
hmm how do i want to talk about oh shit maybe i need like
food for my brain right now i really need food for the brain
um um but yeah so i had a little detour so i bought uh i
bought everything i basically did not buy anything i need
for the for my vacation well i bought clothes good.
I bought, I have a suitcase.
I have the suitcase.
I have the new suitcase.
Um, and I bought clothes.
Just no shoes.
I, I will buy shoes tomorrow.
You're now an honorary.
Yay.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
I got a suitcase.
I just have, I just did not buy, yeah, I bought my 30th
hoodie.
I bought new cool new custom nails I got winter clothes on
my summer vacation and we have more minions merch yay as a
God intended I have more minions merch for my collection as
intended the nails were cute the nails were cute but I don't
think I'll be using I don't want to use them during the
vacation um i mean i should actually maybe i should i don't
know i should i want to look oh yeah and i got my eyebrows
um done too um since like i'll be traveling so i had to um i
had oh my gosh i hate so i only do it whenever i have to
like travel so like obviously i don't care because i was
like no one's gonna no one's gonna look at me i'm always in
at home so like like i said i told you guys I have really
thick eyebrows.
So whenever I do have to go, I have to get my eyebrows, like
I got to get my eyebrows threaded and everything.
And also like my bros, like this is why it sucks being a
woman.
This is why it fucking sucks being a woman.
So I don't care.
I usually don't care and about like threading my eyebrows
and stuff like that.
Just because that's like, who's going to look at me?
i didn't get it in um but like but it's like it's like
they're like it's like wild and so i had to get it threaded
uh but i don't like get it like super short skinny or
anything i just want to make sure it's like trimmed properly
you know like it's not like um no it's not like it's i had i
just get it like trimmed properly to the point where it's
like um it does it's straight and everything not not like a
fucking yeah cleaned up i get cleaned up and i like trim it
a little bit so it's not like too sick but then it's like i
hate it because it's like after you're done and they show
you the mirror your entire like forehead is just red like
it's like i got sunburned and i was like i just see like
because like obviously it was so much hair so then it's like
my entire forehead It just looked like I got fucking
sunburnt and everything.
And I'm like, ah.
Yeah.
So, so just girl things.
Just lady things.
Yeah, it like stings a little bit.
But like, it's just beauty is pain.
You know what they say?
And I normally, I don't know.
I don't, I don't do it often.
So it's just, so it's more so it's just like whenever I do
get it threaded, it's like a lot of hair.
That's just gone on my head.
All my, like all my fucking eyebrows is just gone.
So I had to get that done.
And then, um, and then, uh, and then I went, obviously I
went straight to go to shopping and everything, um, in
downtown, um, just because like all the i just want to get
nice shoes i have to get nice shoes because i don't have any
um one of the places i have to go apparently is that there's
a dress code um because i have to go to somewhere that needs
a dress code and i was told that like if i show up with
sandals or sneakers they will turn me away i don't have any
nice shoes anyway instead of doing that i came back with
nendroids i i i came back so instead of trying to buy nice
shoes or like heels or whatever because i own i legitimately
i own two pairs of shoes i own sneakers and sandals and then
i went to downtown hoping to get a nice pair of shoes and i
came back with three minion nendroids i plus too uh yeah but
now you have i got a little distracted there just a little
bit went out to buy lumitons and come back with minions um i
also need to buy new sandals i might just buy crocs honestly
i don't know i i don't know what are these sandals i really
love um because they always feel really good um what is that
brand i've always had this brand when it comes to saddles
let me grab it real quick uh just a little bit distracted of
course give me a sec
it's a german brand because they're very efficient berkinson
i think is that what called Birkenstock Birkenstock yeah I I
been wearing that brand for for my sandals for like since I
was a okay this is pretty fucked up but you know what I said
earlier beauty is pain so the thing about Birkenstock is
that it's apparently um a type of from what my mom told me
um the reason why these shoes are uh famous um is because of
like German engineering you know it's like like German
engineering and apparently I don't know if this was a lie or
not but it like molds your feet to make it look like to make
it like not flat feet so like when I was growing up I had
flat feet And obviously, my mom was not happy about that.
So, yeah.
So, my feet was, like, sort of, like, flat.
So, it's like, you know how there's, like, normal feet,
like, growing up.
It's, like, normal feet is, like, there's, like, a shape to
it.
You know, like, an arch.
Like, you know, like, like, it's like a, like, you know,
like, you know, bodies have hips and stuff.
So some people are born where the feet doesn't have a hit,
like have like hips.
So, so some people are unfortunately born in a way where
there's no hips to the foot.
So, and yeah, no hip on, no hip.
It was not no hourglass figure on the foot.
So that was sort of me growing up as a kid.
And my mom did not like that.
So like she would make me wear these like shoes that would
like get like would mold your feet into an hourglass figure
for the feet.
So that's why I wore a lot, growing up, I wore a lot of
ortho, what's it called, Birkenstock shoes?
And I don't know, I don't have flat feet anymore at least.
I don't know how it worked though.
I don't have, I have normal feet now.
So yeah, I wore a lot of like orthopedic type shoes growing
up as well.
And then I was like, we're not reversing.
We're going to make sure it doesn't become flat.
anymore so I wore a lot of like orthopedic shoes that were
purposely that are like helps like unflatten your feet yeah
yeah so um so I had I I wore a lot of Birkenstock shoes
because you know German engineering and everything and they
also help with molding your feet to make sure it they have
an hourglass figure Thank you, Germans, I guess.
You do know how to engineer good shoes.
Racky, thank you for the super chat.
And they're very comfy, though.
They're very comfy.
So I need to find a place to buy Birkenstock shoes.
Because they're long-lasting.
The great thing about German shoes is that they're very
long-lasting.
Because I've owned that pair of shoes.
for like five years now, five plus years.
And like now it's sort of starting to break apart, sort of
in a way where like the rubber is peeling a little.
My good friend says you have to cast, thank you for the
super chat, thank you, thank you.
Hello, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
My kamiyoshi understands my pain, but in all seriousness,
what actually helped is doing exercise, like rolling a glass
cup, towel grabs, using towel, I'm thinking of a super chat.
Someone has a lot of experience.
I don't know.
I know my, I have my feet fixed at least.
I know that.
I don't know.
I don't remember what I did, what my parents did, but it's
fixed.
Correspondent.
Thank you.
A super chat.
Got a job for you.
621.
We received a request from TPS.
Procure and Consume Substance.
A name of a super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, where am I?
Where am I right now?
Uh, Jared.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Brooks were very popular during my high school era.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Raksha, thank you, thank you.
Love your cover.
Girlfriend, Doki.
It sort of took me back down memory lane.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, my God, I'm so...
I'm really happy everybody loves the girl friend cover.
You know what was scary?
When I was in the Uber to go to downtown, I had like...
I was just like, you know, on Discord doing, like, doing
messaging work stuff.
And then I heard, Hey, hey, you, you.
And I was just like, because I was just like, oh, shit.
Because I was like, is this my cover or is this Avriel
Levine version?
And then I realized like, you know, the Uber was just
playing it on the rate, like playing, like was just on the
radium.
So it was literally just Avriel Levine.
It was the, you know, the original version.
But like the hey, hey, you part, my part is so similar to.
the original Avril Lavigne part, like just like, hey, hey,
you, you, because like, it sounded so similar.
And I, you know, and, but it was like that section, and I
like, like took on my, like took on my headphones, and I was
just like, and I was just like, oh, okay, it's Avril
Lavigne, he's on the radio.
Like, it like, it legitimately jump scared me.
I was just like, oh my God.
Uh, oh, but yeah, anyway, I gotta go find tomorrow and go
find a place that sells Birkenstock.
Birkenstock shoes.
Highly recommended.
If you ever are, if you're ever looking for sandals, the
Birkenstock shoes are very comfy, very long, very expensive.
Oh my God.
Never mind.
I, uh, very expensive.
I just realized how expensive.
they are i i just i just i looked at the website yeah hey
hey it lasted me five plus years guys legit you can you only
need to buy one pair of sandals and then that's five plus
years investment maybe six i think i've had these sandals
for like wait okay pre pre-corpo i've had it pre-corpo so
Definitely more than six years.
I'm paying for the quality.
So, oh, I like the Arizona chunky.
Oh, that's cute.
Look at these pairs, guys.
This is cute.
Look at the Arizona.
Oh, Arizona.
Chunky, guys.
I like the color.
It's very cute.
Oh, my God.
These are cute shoes.
Sorry, I'm looking at shoes right now.
Oh, this one's cute.
All right, anyway.
Tomorrow, tomorrow, I will not get distracted.
Guys, tomorrow, tomorrow, we will get shoes.
I will not get distracted.
And tomorrow, I'll be like, hey, guys, I came back with
some...
hey everybody I might have come back with minions utensils
over time to sponsor oh she may be a dokey sandal swordsman
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you I came back
with minion crocs did you guys okay so I don't remember what
I okay wait oh my gosh guys wait there are minion crocs
there I Oh, I bought the Minions Bath Bomb.
Can I take a picture of it?
I don't remember.
I bought the Minions Bath Bomb a couple of weeks ago, but I
forgot to show it to you guys.
It was in Bed Bath.
You know how Bed Bath Beyond?
I also bought the Yoshi Egg.
I haven't used it yet.
Because there's a gotcha with the Yoshi Egg where if you put
the Bath Bomb in there, there's a chance where it'll turn
into a chance to start bleeding because you get...
a red Yoshi or some shit.
Anyway, I used the Minion Backbomb like a couple of weeks
ago.
I had it for like, I think like one to two months.
I've had it for one to two months and then like I finally
used it a couple of weeks ago because I was trying to, I was
trying to use it for a special occasion, you know?
I was, I was trying to, I tried to figure out when to use
it.
I wanted to use it on a very special occasion.
I used it on the day I watched the Minions movie, like
post-Minions movie, and I was like, that was a good movie.
It's time to use the Minions Bat Bomb.
What counts as a special occasion?
So I finally used it, I think a couple of weeks ago.
Shake my head.
All right, okay, anyway, all right, let's play the game.
We're going to try and get the first ending.
I don't, you guys said that.
uh the first ending would take like five was it five levels
so that's our goal we're gonna try we would try and get the
first ending today and then maybe i know you guys a lot of
guys want me to do all the endings so i might actually try
i'll try i'll i'll think about it during the vacation and
then um i might do like a one go at it to get all the true
ending maybe maybe maybe I have to, I'll use the vacation to
think about it.
So, so we're going to try to get the first ending first.
Chad, thank you.
Thank you.
I've been watching a while.
Love the new skins.
Thank you.
I don't know.
It's my favorite skin.
So we haven't, we've been using this one.
We've been using this one the last couple of streams just
because of how much, I don't know.
I'm just, I just love using, I just love it.
It's basically how I feel every day.
Literally every day I wake up for streaming.
This is how I feel.
This is Medi fan club back for a sponsorship.
Can we get five big Medis again?
Go out to you the super chat.
Thank you.
The ultimate EP.
It really is.
I feel like this is how I actually feel every day when I
start stream.
I'm just I wake up or what I am every day.
I wake up in my pajamas.
Go live.
And then.
go back to sleep and then wake up in my pajamas go live and
then go back to sleep
i am what i am all right here we go finally we're gonna play
i i i know i'm sorry i've been like all over the place
because i know like um i uh i tried to come back earlier as
early as i can but it was I got distracted, guys.
I got really distracted.
But I'm still trying to fit as many streams as I can for you
guys.
Because, you know, like I said, I will be gone for a couple
of days till the 7th.
I'll be back on the 7th.
So I didn't want to give you guys as much dokyum as
possible.
So you guys won't die from starvation.
So I tried my best.
I tried my best to...
Stuff as many streams as I can in between my vacation prep I
got distracted by the minions I don't want you guys to
starve I will have videos uploaded though while I'm gone
They're just like edited videos so there's not like new
content It's not like new content but like there's some
edited videos that are coming in You guys want to rewatch
some you know re watch some uh some streams and stuff bad um
all right anyway i'm looking for sponsors oh wait oh wait
you're right quelled quelled quelled already that was with
sponsorship oh my god you pre-gamed the sponsor all right
back giving me five big medis all right going do we have any
other offers the sponsor are good old goon bot a good old
goon bot going once going twice does anyone want to counter
quills offered a sponsor goon bot today hello miss bird I
would like to neppers thank you for the magenta snoop no
snoopa thank you for the magenta soup thank you thank you
snipe by neppers I would like to advertise for goon dine
systems manufacture of high quality Dragoon made rocket
subsystems.
Our logo is a rocket with a payload bearing on the tip and
two round fuel tanks at the tip.
And where would you like to put that logo?
That phrase.
Zyko, thank you.
Superchat, thank you, thank you.
Congrats on defeating Metra, Melania.
Last room, thank you.
I think, yeah, oh my god, that bitch, I'm glad she's dead
and no one will ever love her.
She died alone and afraid.
Anyway, Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome.
All right, let me see if I know how to make that.
Oh, my stomach is growling.
It's like I haven't eaten yet.
Okay.
Rocket with payload fairing on the tip and two round fuel
tanks at the base.
Anything but Medis.
Well, Airborne Ninja, thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you.
Airborne Ninja, are you okay with Nepre's logo?
all right here all right let's see we gotta find a rocket
okay let me look look it up airport ninja what do you think
about nepper's logo design of gunardine systems generational
hater let's see sure all right the court offers 150
sponsorship all right it's a rocket okay is there a rocket
in the pre-sale Let's see.
There must be a rocket somewhere.
That is a crab.
I mean, this is like mechas, so there should be a rocket,
right?
There's no way there's no rockets in here.
There's a... There's like skulls and everything.
There's a fucking motherfucking T-Rex and no rocket.
They gave me a fucking... You know what?
A bullet is close enough.
A bullet is like a rocket if you think about it.
There was one.
I did not see a single rocket, guys.
All I saw, I saw a bullet on the weapons page.
There's a rocket.
I'm looking at fucking presets right now.
Oh, rocket is in weapons.
Okay.
I'm at the rock.
Is this weapons?
Is this?
Next to a grenade.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Well, let me grab it again.
That does not look like, uh, I mean, fine.
Yeah, we'll make it, make it pink.
And then, uh, how do I rotate again?
All right, there you go.
All right.
The rocket, rocket payload bearing on the tip.
Confirm in that payload.
What does the payload look like?
Ooh, 15 minutes.
Uh...
Uh, which one is the payload?
Is it this?
What would the payload bearing on...
What would the payload thing look like?
I mean, at this.
this point if I'm like you want all right let me adjust the
color just the color hello let me adjust the color sir hello
I want to adjust the color the explosion symbol it's alright
whatever I give up all right let's see do we didn't get
demonetized no there's no way there's no way There, he has
happy now.
Two round fuel tanks at the base.
All right, fuel tanks.
What would look like a fuel tank?
I feel like maybe...
Let's see.
I feel like that looks like a fuel tank, right?
Just the earth.
The earth is...
The earth is nature's fuel.
If you think about it, guys.
The...
The earth is technically nature's fuel.
There we go.
Yeah, the earth is a fuel tank.
It is!
Bigger?
Just because you said that?
It's...
really the guys global global cooling is real okay it's
global cooling there yeah
all right i think we're good uh save and the p is stored on
on the globe guys not our fault guys global warming and
cooling is real that's when you know all right all right all
right neppers from all right goondide thank you for the
thank you for the sponsorship gooner dine system cats thank
you for magenta soup but thank you thank you i caught her
offer with boring to eat it's too late the offer was 150 150
cats on to goon uh add on to gunerdad's uh sponsor chat
thank you super chat thank you i demand more technically
technically there it is if you think about it there's
something funny on the radar looks like a giant hot dog get
your hot dogs here all right let's see well we know where to
put this part uh eat cows let's see We know where to put
this.
Where is it?
It looks.
There you go.
Uh...
Alright, let's see.
Oops.
I figured out how to move this again.
It's been a while.
Oh.
Nope.
All right, how the fuck do I move this?
It's been too long.
I'm trying to move the fucking bot.
Excuse me.
How do I reposition my robot?
Bottom front?
No, I'm trying to reposition him.
No, that's not what I wanted.
Guys, how do I reposition?
my bot.
Oh, there it is.
IJKL.
Sorry, I don't read.
Ah, it doesn't work.
Just stick it up his ass.
I mean, the side is sort of.
You know, it's gonna have the logo on the ass, you know?
I feel like that works.
Or we just do it here, but it's not as funny.
I'll put it here.
I'll put it right here.
Alright, let's see.
There we go.
And then we'll put...
You know what?
It's like flames, you know?
Since we got two spots, we'll have a tiny version of it
here.
There we go.
Alright, I think that's good.
All right, save and quit.
What a beautiful mecha.
All right.
Thank you for the sponsorship, guys.
I really appreciate it.
That's how we're going to continue getting our big booms.
All right, which one's my girlfriend's mission?
Eliminate Cinder Carla.
Eliminate Cinder Carla of Overseer.
Eliminate Ford of the Vespers.
Which one did my girlfriend want in?
real girlfriend who has no body or whatsoever uh
kill Carla do not take her admission but she's so hot she's
but guys guys she said like we could go to third base if I
do it guys the voices in my my girlfriend voice in my head
said like she would let me you know she would like me let me
touch their aura if I if I if I do it if I if I imagine hard
enough it's like it's like she's giving me a kiss air or a
beconian overseer is planning to burn the coral to Of
course, no problem, darling.
Happy wife is happy life, guys.
G-Toki.
How come Toki tank is too payload?
T-Toki, thank you.
Thank you.
We'll take advantage of the confusion while the corporations
and overseer are fighting and eliminate Carla.
I understand how you feel about betraying Walter's last
wishes and taking on Carla.
but still i want you to give me a chance i'm not asking
walter's hound but raven the independent mercenary
all right that's my happy wife soon to be wife after i
killed carla all right what's the other briefing
here's a situation tourist Archibus has sent its entire
force It's not my wife's voice Why the fuck would I do this?
That's betraying her I've got our backs to the wall right
now That's where you come in
Leave the grunts to chatty and the others I found someone
just right for you For me?
V1 Freud The ace leading the corporate force
Walter left me one last card me once you're in there's no
turning back can I count on you yeah
a happy wife equals happy life guys she'll let me through
let me get to third base where warriors are gonna touch and
do it walter away but they bend they both start with w
that's so high
oh let me hear a voice one last time maybe that'll influence
my decision raven this job comes for me air i'm a baconian
Overseer is planning to burn the coral to extinction.
I want to keep that from happening.
Yeah, you want me to kill her parents?
We just started moving in together when she moved into my
head.
We have only one choice.
We'll take advantage of the confusion while the corporations
and Overseer are fighting.
And eliminate Carla.
you feel about betraying Walter's last wishes and taking on
Carla.
But still, I want you to give me a chance.
I'm not asking Walter's hound, but Raven.
Money over wife.
I do like money.
And I do like my wife.
Genesis Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
What would make sense as my first ending?
Guys.
I want to give you guys the best first ending.
What would make sense for my first ending?
Choices are hard.
You're making me choose between wife or money.
And that's like, that's so, don't tell my wife.
Don't tell my wife that.
But like, money and wife is sort of hard to pick between the
two.
Go with the heart.
Oh, you know what my heart wants.
Don't tell my wife it's between her and money, though.
No.
You know what my heart wants, guys.
You know what my heart truly wants in the end.
Got more money.
Guys, more money means more minions, merch.
I could always, can I always get more money in the end?
Maybe if I have more money, I'll have more wives running
down on me.
The true end of the truth.
I'm sorry, wife.
I was born to be a mercenary.
more dollar sign dollar sign dollar sign means more bigger
booms like a wife like what i can always return to a wife i
could never return to dollar sign dollar sign dollar sign
here i go God pays the bills.
My true wife.
Big boom.
Alright, here I go.
I'm sorry.
I was born a mercenary first.
My true love.
The biggest boom.
My first love.
all right let's roll we've still got time until v1 deployed
but money can wipe my tears once a mercenary always a
mercenary oh shit I forgot that was my weapon not gonna lie
you know I said how about all this yeah how how do you think
I'll do all this how do you think those Louis Vuitton were
We're free!
Alright, that is...
You don't understand!
How else did I find all those Louis Vuitton aura bags?
Let Chatti handle the starboard wing for now.
You need to deal with the target.
Oh, grab over here.
All right, nice.
I think he's dead?
I can't tell.
Oh, my God.
Wait, where did he go?
There we go.
Whoa!
What the fuck?
Why is that not blowing up?
Hello.
I showed you my missiles.
Please blow up.
Please go boom.
There we go.
Alright, nice.
Oh, my food's almost here.
Wait, I gotta make sure I take the call for the intercom.
I show you my missiles.
Please, big boom.
Please explode.
Alright, I just gotta make sure.
Alright, we go in.
Oh, shit!
Whoops!
Guys, I took damage.
I gotta use my HP.
You don't That I just took...
That one hit!
Changes everything!
Oh shit.
Okay, I didn't...
He just called me.
I gotta be sure I...
Oh shit, he bashes me!
Oh, if only I didn't take that!
Okay, it's fine.
Wait, how do I repair?
How did I...
Oh, my God.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
My alt tab, X and the alt tab!
Oh, yeah.
I pressed so many buttons.
Guys, guys, I...
I was so hungry.
You don't understand.
I was...
I was distracted with food.
You don't understand, guys.
You don't understand.
Looks like we've secured the area.
Resupply while you can.
Dude, my food was calling for me.
Wait, how do I scanning?
Okay, V.
I was trying to scan and actually press C.
Guys, you don't understand.
There's no food.
I have no...
I have no fuel right now.
Alright, don't understand how I buy all this mini merch and
power VVIP series about money.
And port ninja.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
all right let's see let me make sure the food is all right
they haven't put down my food yet it's gonna be my first
meal all right i'll make sure i don't accidentally try to
see again enemy detected coming in hot it's okay they're not
here yet so i'm safe
i'm hurrying the door just hasn't opened yet what do you
want me to do
It's not like I could just bash open the door Boom Boom
Nice Oh shit hey player 2 We finally plugged in the
Controller for you Hey player 2 Where I got this Oh What the
fuck?
Okay, I didn't realize my range is so low.
Alright.
Hey, buddy.
Why is he looking at me?
I thought you were going to draw fire for me.
Oh my god.
Buddy, why is he looking at me?
Why aren't you doing your job, buddy?
Why aren't you there?
Oh, yeah, just fucking...
Of course, you're going to kill Steel.
Alright, nice.
Oh my god, come on.
There we go.
Why is he looking respectfully at me?
You said you were going to draw a cover fire.
Oh, we're the real chair duo, bro.
Oh my god, we're matching.
You must be Raven.
Never sparred with one of Walter's hounds before.
That's me.
Does it better be worth it?
trash out of the way oh shit i hope he doesn't die oh i
think he's dead
okay um guys i think he died bro he had one job he had
chatty chatty you had one job How did you fuck that up?
I literally asked you, I hope you don't die.
Wait, how do I shield again?
Oh, look at that.
He's having a great time.
Control R, right?
Okay, I just want to make sure.
Alright, nice.
Oh, I got it.
I got it out just in case.
That's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
That's no longer fine.
I just realized my HP.
I was not paying attention.
As always.
It's okay, guys.
I was not paying attention.
It's okay.
This.
It doesn't matter.
That fucked me, right?
Oh, yeah.
I sense that.
I sense that tension.
And I right there.
Look at that.
Boy.
that V1 fried.
Oh!
That's why I'm all in on the Polly Market.
I think he's okay.
Are you okay there, buddy?
We're supposed to be the wheelchair duel.
I got him.
Nice.
I think he'll be okay.
Okay.
All right, my food's here.
Hey, wife, I'm back with more money that I got for us.
You're still okay that I didn't pick you, right?
That you're not my first choice?
You're okay with that.
You didn't back him up.
He was an AI I developed.
Well, you didn't back him up?
Carla!
You're fucking stupid.
What do you mean taking the life out of him?
What do you mean Backin' bro It's like 101 Tech 101 Always
back up
Jesus If you love them you would back him up You know set a
respawn point If you love him I mean if setting respawn
point is like Bro people clone dogs Come on Like
I would absolutely clone it homie
all right my food's here I mean I feel like if I was able to
clone my dog I would if I was able to clone my pet I would
do it if it didn't cost millions of dollars
Yo Kiyama, say so dragon, I'm nothing but innocent and cool
and yellow, right?
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh wait, I need, oh, they didn't give me a fork.
I, they always never give me a fork.
That's the fork.
I'll be right back.
All right.
Oh, all right, I got my food.
Let me take a few bites before we go on.
for oh what's this is this for my half buck or what how it's
pronounced I don't pronounce it properly okay that's my
spaghetti and chicken and then this one would be my half
buck I don't know that I'm pronouncing it is this oh it's
lemon oh my I should have stuck Oh, it's lemon!
It's lemon!
I was like, what is this clear yellow clear yellow liquid in
this container?
It was lemon.
It was lemon juice.
I should not have stuck my tongue in it.
All right, let me try this Filipino noodle dish that you
guys recommended me to try.
Oh, it's rice noodle.
Okay, honest opinion, guys.
I didn't realize it was rice noodle.
I don't like rice noodle that much.
That's just a preference, though.
I'm not a big...
I didn't realize this was rice noodle.
I don't know.
It's just a preference.
I like thick noodles.
I always get the thickest noodles.
I don't like angel hair.
I just don't like thin noodles I don't like angel hair I
don't like rice noodles I don't like really thin noodle I
always get the thickest like spaghetti if I if I make
spaghetti and every oh I love udon if I make spaghetti or
something I get like the thickest spaghetti noodle um so I'm
I'm just a thick noodles enjoy I like it thick you know the
sauce is good I just don't like I just don't like even ramen
I get the thickest ramen noodles too because you know how
you have a choice between like the thin noodles, thin ramen
noodles, or the thick ramen noodles, I always get the thick
ones.
And now when I make a request, I'd be like, they're like,
what kind of noodles?
I'll be like, the thick ones.
I've seen it.
I was, I thought it was, I was thinking it looked like rice
noodles, but I wasn't like super sure in the pictures.
But yeah, now that I took a bite, I was like,
like the hmm I like the sauce there's rice noodles right or
is it vermicelli noodles is that I don't know I've always
pronounced stuff wrong oh my gosh oh there was a little very
sour taste there yeah yeah
okay i'm done with my rice noodles now the main course
my spaghetti i love spaghetti my spaghetti you like thin
cantonese egg noodles i like thick cantonese egg noodles i
always get the thickest noodles there's a thick version
all right i'm gonna get my Yeti now.
Um, bum.
Alright, after I take a couple of bites, we'll keep playing.
Sorry, guys.
Only had, this is my first meal of the day.
I was running through adrenaline the entire time.
Get the wide ones, not the thin ones, but the, I'm okay
with, like, the flat wide ones, because that's also sort of
thick.
I just don't like, I don't know, I just don't like the
texture of the thin noodles.
That's just me.
I'm just not like I said I just a texture issue for me I
just don't like the texture of the thin noodles because
like when it's super thin it feels mushy you know you know
it's just like it's just a mushy feeling I want two all
right one more bite and then we'll game and we'll progress
bite of my chicken.
Also true, it gets soggy real quick too.
Can I eat it like freshly prepped?
Or it gets too soggy and then it's extra mushy and I don't
fuck with that.
Hmm.
Okay guys, this is a little TMI, but I was so tilted.
Because I got home and I was like can't wait to start my
vacation tomorrow and then the moon started shining I went
to the bathroom and I saw the moon that's right
What?
So...
I know, right?
Why did it have to happen?
The moment I'm about to start my vacation.
That's so marvelous.
I'm like, yippee!
At least it's not six months.
You remember that?
I remember how long last time.
True.
That was crazy.
I should have seen a doctor, but then I was just like
Shouldn't be that bad Oh, I always kept thinking maybe next
month Maybe I should have yeah I was thinking like yeah be
that maybe next month you get I kept thinking like it
wouldn't last that long it'll come it'll come to me as per
tradition cyber thank you for the akasupa thank you thank
you thank you thank you again
daily reminder that i can't outrun time
all right sorry i said one more bite and then i'm taking
several more bites but this time last last bite guys for
real all right second last bite this is the last last bite
for real I just realized how much I like food after I
finally ate it I was like whoa guys did you know food tastes
fucking amazing oh my god why don't we do this more often
have you guys ever tried this thing called food like I
Holy shit.
Why don't we do this more?
God, I wish food was real.
Hey.
Wow.
After I ate, my headache's gone.
Who would have thought there was a correlation between that?
Guys, I fixed my headache.
I started to eat it.
Holy shit
Damn Only my doctor would have known
Problems can be fixed with food and money
Guys You should tell your doctor about that Maybe they don't
know that either
Nine out of ten doctors recommend eating
The 10th one died of starvation.
All right.
Last, last, last, last bite.
Doctors hate her for speaking the truth.
See, if you started eating, you would see doctors less, and
doctors don't want you to know that.
All right, let's see.
see all right i'm done i said a little bit but i'll eat that
later because i don't want to
here i'm gonna wash my hands i'm gonna wash my hands and it
will continue
i also realized my adrenaline i'm getting better at walking
around i don't know because like I don't know if it was
adrenaline or whatever, but like, um, when I was like
shopping, um, I wasn't tired at all.
Like my feet didn't hurt at all or anything.
And I wasn't wearing sneakers or anything too.
So like, because I was like walking around for like three
plus, I, it was definitely adrenaline.
I think it was the adrenaline of just not eating a lot.
I don't know.
Because like, when I was in LA, I was so tired.
Like, just like, even like walking at Anime Expo.
I did like two hours tops and then I was just tired like my
feet was like sore and I was like I was just like oh man
like I don't know because there was like a lot of people too
um and then when I was like walking around today I was like
walking around for like three plus hours and I was fine I I
don't know why I was just like I didn't my like my feet
didn't hurt and like and i was just like i was just fine and
i was like carrying a lot of stuff too yeah i was like in
survival mode yeah and when i like when i got home i wasn't
my like i'm not tired like my legs aren't tired my feet
wasn't tired uh or anything i was just like i was okay and i
was carrying a lot of stuff too because i was shopping so it
wasn't like wasn't like i was carrying I was like at anime
expo when I carry too much stuff I would be like SOS to my
staff and then my staff would pick up my stuff and I just
kept on shopping I was like I'm too many things and I like
texted my staff and they come pick me up and they would like
we like meet somewhere and they like got all my bags and
then I kept going on but like today yeah so yeah and then
but then like shopping.
Like, reload.
Yeah, reload.
I was reloading.
Yeah.
And then, uh, but then like today, you know, I was walking
by myself going, walking around shopping and everything.
And, uh, but like, I carrying everything by myself and like,
I was still fine.
I don't know.
It was just pure adrenaline.
My body was just on survival mode or anything.
Or I just got better at longer.
I got I've been traveling so much.
Maybe I just got like I got better at like just walking
around because I've been traveling so much lately.
Could be adrenaline.
I think it's called I think it was adrenaline.
But the thing is I didn't have I only ate like a snack
during the entire day.
Like a I only ate like a pastry.
That was it.
That's all I ate today.
like very surprised how like i built up the endurance or
some shit i'll brief you on the job tourist
the xylem is just inside the carmen line skimming the border
of outer space
meanwhile archivist still hasn't taken full control of a
rubicon's closure system they're locked out of the satellite
cannons making this their hands my stamina or some We'll be
fighting their interceptor fleet in the air.
But we're not totally screwed.
This area of space is thick with residual coral from the
fire's divus.
Make a dip in the coral flow.
And you could draw on an unlimited source of energy.
That's all a tourist.
Break through the fleet.
And the vascular plan is ours.
Seems pretty simple, Carla.
Alright, here we go.
Time to do or die.
oh shit hope it's not die let's get our laughs while we can
it's one of the coolest missions i'll see about that all
right it's time to fly somber and medias cyber think of a
super chat thank you main system activating combat mode let
the games begin
But where am I going?
Destroyed.
Oh, this?
Who am I?
Oh, this one?
Oh, I see.
Don't worry, I got you.
Oh, you're still alive?
There we go.
Don't worry, I got the next one.
Alright.
Yeah?
You got hit shot first!
Another one!
Where's the next one?
Oh shit.
Are these all next ones?
How?
Wait, all of these?
Oh, shit.
All of these?
Alright.
We've lost the Vanguard.
Main fleet.
Maintain formation.
Oh, shit.
There's no way.
Threat the needle.
Threat the needle!
Alright.
You got hit me first, bitch.
Oh, shit.
Wait, I think he hit me first.
He was like, fat?
That's a third interceptor to go down.
Where's the next one?
Oh, there it is.
All right.
Because I think he hit me first.
I'm trying to boost.
I don't know why I stopped.
I wanted to take in the scenery, I guess.
It was a pretty day to die.
One plus to the tourist.
Main fleet two, you lost hold of the line.
Which one's the next for me?
I'm going you You're up next if that were to be clone where
his name be dad Me thank you agenda super.
Thank you.
Just be it dad.
I'll just oh shit Oh my god.
Whoops.
I might tank that Have you guys heard that story?
Okay, this is a fucked up like story, but I don't remember
if this was like some guy's shit posting but oh I remember
which animal it was but like um there was a story of some
guy some dad um they kept replacing their kid's pet and be
like because they were like oh my pet is like it has the
world record for oldest the oldest animal in the world and
then the dad had to confess and was like We've been
replacing his pet every couple of years because we didn't
want we didn't want to sell him Yeah, but I don't remember
like what animal it was was a hamster.
I just remember they just kept replacing him over and over
again
Fuck this I'm not like I'm got scared
Okay, we got one down All right, we'll go with the one above
me.
I feel that I mean, it would make sense All right, last one
Hey, yeah Saw your friends die.
Don't worry.
You're not the exception Oh,
that should be all of them Yippee What's that?
What's what?
Where?
I'm five On the what?
Oh shit Wait, what do you mean we're not done yet?
I just killed 20 ships
Who's there?
Hey there.
Friendshape?
Here we are, buddy.
Hey, buddy.
You were just another threat to Robo.
Rusty?
Wait, why does he get the pro tag?
What does he get?
Epic music.
Oh, shit.
Rusty.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Rusty, wait.
Wait.
I got a regen.
Regions, I couldn't stop you.
Wait, Rusty, wait, wait, Rusty, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, God.
He's healing, that's not fair!
Rusty, no!
Oh, shit.
Wait, am I the bad guy?
Wait a minute.
There's no way.
wait a minute am I a baddie no right no no I'm fighting for
good no there's no way oh shit this is bad this is bad this
is so bad oh no wait a minute are we No!
Evil has been defeated.
There's no way.
I'm doing this for justice, right?
That's not fair.
Rusty caught me with my pants down.
I had no ears.
Oh, why does he get the epic for good music?
I don't get it.
I did everything right.
Oh shit
Alright Not me, right?
You're not talking about me, right?
I'm all about the justice
Oh, whenever I show up, my music somehow is like demonic
music You must have chosen something but sacrificed
something You found your purpose, didn't you?
Hey, see, we're still buddies.
He still calls me a friend.
Okay, nice.
Alright, nice.
I should kill him.
No, no, no.
I'm not the bad guy.
Of course not.
Can't be me.
Oh, shit!
He's comboing me!
There we go.
Let's go.
Wait, what?
Wait, I know.
I was gonna do like, cool guys, don't look at explosions
moment.
I was just like, I did it, guys.
Cool guys, don't look at it.
Wait, you're not dead?
There we go.
Look at that.
Good prevails yet again.
See, if he was a real protagonist, He would have won.
I'll remember him.
Oh, I'll remember him.
Oh, what?
Carla?
I'm not your buddy, pal.
Look, if he was truly the protagonist, why is he dead?
I'm just saying.
Satellite cannons?
Copy, yeah, they chose to celebrate Papa.
They even super chat.
Thank you.
There's no way the corpse took the clone.
Hey, he fought for their corpos.
Guys, come on.
Is he truly a good guy?
Zyko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're a villain because of money.
Rusty, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, though, thank you for the super chat.
I did everything right.
Women actively tried to blow up.
of the planet.
Thank you, Superchat.
Thank you.
Oh, cool.
I got his head.
Augmented human.
C-4621.
Entering standard mode.
Alright, cool.
And I got his legs.
Alright, shut down the closure.
Oh, I should put on his head.
Alright, let's see.
Which one is his head?
I just said I'll remember him You ain't got your head That's
what you know is real doom yowie This is him right Oh your
head Okay attitude system recovery This one right Oh that's
fucked up Using your Using your dead boyfriend's head
Alright there we go Assemble Gundam Nero thank you for the
super chat Thank you thank you i'm wearing his skin guys i'm
like what's his name um i'm like not jason what's that guy i
wore like chainsaw massacre guy all
right shut down the closure satellite yeah i'm like leather
face the toxic yawian thank you thank you for the super chat
everybody thank you thank you
you know that you you've made your choice then
i must do my duty of what all right as a rubiconian but i
made so much money you can buy that new those new shoes you
wanted for your virtual feet
wait wait no no wait don't leave me wait arya i have so much
dollar sign dollar sign dollar signs now.
I went up a dollar sign.
I do thank you for the super chat thing.
No!
I don't have...
Oh no, she's gonna take 50%.
I didn't make her sign it.
This ship's gonna be roughed up.
I didn't make her sign that thing where she doesn't get 50%.
I didn't make her sign of freedom.
Why did I make her sign of freedom before I took the money?
Good luck out there.
Oh, no.
I fucked up, guys.
I thought she would be so happy when she saw all those
dollar signs and then instead she filed for a divorce.
I know you can still see it.
The voices of the quarrel.
And yet you turned your back on your shared potential.
Oh, shit.
Was that from...
Did you build this from the money I just got us?
Okay, how is she able to afford this?
Oh, now she has a body after I've made us lots of money.
Okay.
I see how it is.
She's here to deliver the divorce paper.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, I thought you loved me.
Oh, shit, she's so fast.
Oh, why is she so fast?
Oh, my gosh!
But we can still be together!
We can still be together!
I just had to- Money was here first!
Money was here first!
You don't- How else were you able to afford that beautiful
Mecca?
Oh my gosh, she's so much better than me.
Oh, at least she can't heal, right?
Do you think she can heal?
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
Okay, maybe I'll just do this.
Okay.
Oh my...
Do I do nothing to her?
Like, what the fuck is my...
What is my damage compared to her?
Oh my god.
She's so fast.
I've already, I keep losing sight of her.
Please.
Yeah, no shit.
I don't know what to do.
Where did she go?
okay oh
my god she's so much faster than the mecha millennia oh
that's what a beautiful view of just a tank oh my god is
this goodbye this is truly goodbye
goodbye goodbye cruel world
oh my god i'm not meant to fly how could you do this to
someone in a wheelchair
holy shit oh my god all right i might I might need the
bunker
Fight back guys, I'm trying to fight back
She's a woman scorn There's no fighting back against a woman
that's angry You might as well admit defeat
What do you do when woman mad?
It's a hopeless last cause!
You never win!
It's like never winning in an argument when she's mad!
You just buy her flowers and then hope to God you don't
sleep on the couch!
Guys, why didn't I choose the wife?
Why did I not choose the wife?
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I would.
Ah!
Oh, God.
I wish there was, like, the Dark Souls dodge.
Oh!
My god!
She's so fast!
Oh my god, where am I?
Where am I?
Okay All right, all right, all right, all right, where's my
eye frames?
Okay, I think it's time.
We gotta get the bunker.
all right let's see where's my moonlight sword okay bunker
tab all right we'll just start pummeling just cuz you're a
woman doesn't mean I won't pummel you
just cuz you're my wife doesn't mean I won't use it
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
How am I doing worse right now?
How am I?
Oh, my God.
I can't hit anything.
I'm taking every shot.
Oh, this is so much worse than Melania.
This is so much worse than Mecca, Melania.
This is actually so much worse than Mecca Melania.
Where did she go?
Okay.
There's so much worse.
Oh my god.
Okay, we got one shot in at least.
What?
Oh my god, I'm not meant to fly.
I truly was not meant to fly.
the fly guys I'm just in a wheelchair please I'm in a
wheelchair please oh my god don't keep fight back I can't
She's so mad!
I can't, she's so angry at me.
I'm talking to you, this magenta soup, but thank you.
Do you think I can fracture you?
All right, wait, we gotta use the worm.
Okay, we have...
What's the worm gun again?
Guys, is it this one the detonating bazooka?
Bro, I don't remember which gun was the worm gun, guys.
It's been so long.
The needle.
Was it in this hand?
Which hand had the needle gun?
Which hand was it?
Oh, is it this one?
Oh, there it is.
There you go.
Maybe this will work.
It's my cue.
Back on this way, the sidelines are also shooting each
other.
Do all they give the super chat they can thank you.
Oh, it is.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God!
I saw the potential of our future within me.
I have walked together.
Oh, my God.
Don't make me bring out the guns.
Oh.
Sam!
Nice.
I'll take those.
I'll take that.
Oh, my God.
Oh, wow.
Okay.
Don't worry, maybe.
Oh!
Stab!
Whoa!
Did I hit her?
Oh my god!
I'm so sorry!
Where is she?
I'm not meant to fly!
Oh, my God!
Please, I'm in a wheelchair!
Oh, my God.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, no, she's so angry.
Oh, oh!
Okay, that was...
That was insane from me.
You gotta admit.
Oh, no.
I got it.
I don't know where she...
Oh!
Oh My god, oh my god, I didn't know what to do there.
I didn't I didn't know what to do at that in that situation
That was very very scary That was very that was very very
scary Oh my god
Where did she go?
I mean, we can still do that!
Are you serious?
Bitch!
I didn't mean that, honey.
I didn't mean that.
I did not, you know, I...
You know, I didn't mean that, sweetie.
I didn't...
I wasn't saying that about you.
Yeah.
You know that I was just I was just joking.
You're not a bitch sweetie.
You're you're the love of my life I was just I was just
joking around sweetie Oh my god, I'm so fucked up right now
Oh my god, this is so hard
Oh my god.
I'm so fucked.
Yes.
Oh, come on!
Really?
Oh, I got it.
I hit it first.
I need heals.
Please let me repair.
Are you kidding me?
Oh, shit.
That's all I meant to do.
Oh, fuck.
okay i didn't mean to do that i had a little cool down
period so it fucked me up oh come on oh shit
please don't
oh my god what the build is improving.
I'm figuring out how to play with this build a little bit
more.
Guys, we just need marriage counseling.
We just... Guys, guys, guys.
We just need marriage counseling.
That's it.
That's...
What counseling can't help.
What nothing like a good amount of counseling can do.
Okay.
Come on!
Whoa!
Shit!
Oh shit!
Oh!
Okay, it's fine.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
Oh!
If only my mecha could have- Oh, come on!
Come on!
I'm doing worse.
Wait, wait, we're gonna redo that.
We're gonna redo that.
I'm doing worse.
a little worse right now we're just we're going through
counseling okay this marriage is not toxic whatsoever we're
not a toxic relationship we're just we have our ups and
downs you know like every marriage she
saw the potential oh my God she
saw the potential guys you not hear that God guys guys I
have a feeling I should not be in a wheelchair anymore I
think maybe this game would be a lot easier if I just could
just maybe
But we've been, but we've been wheelcharing it up this
entire time.
Do I really give it up here?
I've been smashing my head against the wheelchair.
Do we really give it up because we have to fight our wife,
so?
Oh my god!
Okay
Okay, oh My god Okay She's so fast.
She's so fast Okay,
it's okay.
It's okay.
Oh My god Oh, that's okay.
It's okay, guys.
I don't have any health packs left, but it's okay.
Oh, shit.
It's okay.
Guys, it was no longer okay.
The halloween locker, okay.
And now for face dip.
Okay, alright, alright, alright.
I figured it out, guys.
I figured it out.
Oh, I forgot to put all my guns.
Okay, after, I figured it out, guys.
Watch this.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Stop watching.
Stop watching, stop watching, stop watching.
Okay.
It's okay.
Oh, come on.
Are you serious?
Okay, the moment I blast this...
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, that's cheating.
That's actually cheating.
This is not fair.
I literally fought you that Mecca.
Oh my god.
Okay, I hate this.
I hate this.
I don't think this is it, guys.
This might not be it.
This, this, this, this might not be it.
This might, this might be, not be it.
Yes, I missed every pile bunker.
Except for, ah!
Okay, all right, never mind.
I will stop you.
I'm carrying you, oh shit.
Oh my gosh, she's like actually machine AI learning from me.
I think she's like, I think she's like learning.
I don't think, there's no way, this is impossible.
She's like learning from how I play every attempt.
Like she's actually AI, she's hacked my save file.
There's no way I refuse to believe.
Oh my god, how the fuck do I dodge that?
a fucking wheelchair okay she's in my head she's actually in
my head oh my yeah just be me I wanted I choose the white
vision why oh my I just need my guns I just need my guns.
Guys, guys, I know what to do.
I know what to do.
Just like Melania.
Just like Mecca Melania.
Just like...
Okay, I got...
I got the hit.
I got one hit in.
Guys, did you see that?
I shot my wife once.
Look, I can do that.
She shot me how many times?
This This is my pass!
Oh my god!
She's so fast!
Why didn't I work out with her?
I realized what the spark of war was that haunt Rubicon!
Oh!
When she told me to go to the gym with her.
Why didn't I do it?
I thought I had shield.
Why did I say it at home when she asked me to go to the gym
with her?
All right.
We're going to get rid of one of the missiles and go with
our trusty gun.
All right.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Pew, pew, pew.
Woo!
Oh, I'm so sorry, honey.
I should have went to the gym with you.
Sorry.
Please.
Just let me stab you.
Alright.
Oh, where is she?
Go to a witch.
If all else fails, I still have...
Oh, my god.
Oh, my.
Why?
What?
She wasn't even in the air!
Oh my god, oh my...
We are strong.
Dangerous.
Oh.
Oh my god.
No, please hold back.
Please hold back.
Please, I'm in a wheelchair.
Please, please hold back.
Please, my insurance doesn't cover for this.
You know it.
You've seen my medical bills.
You've seen my bank account.
oh this is not fair this is not fair guys I don't think the
pew pew is working as I hoped I I don't think it was I
thought it was so clever guys I think I'm doing worse I
think I might be doing worse with it she's too fast for the
fucking guns oh my god the one HP and a dream you think I'll
be okay there is a chance that I will not be okay the only
one okay okay okay okay guns not it but man man I don't
remember what she got oh maybe she can't run away from fire
guys we start with wheelchairs I can't just like Get off the
wheelchair.
It's not like a Christmas miracle, guys.
Oh, my God.
It's not like I just suddenly learned how to walk, guys.
Wait.
I figured it out.
I'm figuring it out, guys.
I just...
There's guys.
Oh my god.
Guys, I figured it out.
Where did she go?
Oh my god!
Okay.
She has to get close to me, right?
shit oh oh my god
okay where did she go where did she go
are you okay
wait wait it's fine it's fine oh it's no longer fine it is
no longer fine i'd not feel good about that
Oh, go!
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
I have fire!
Where does she go?
Oh, my eyes!
Okay, okay, there we go.
Stop.
No!
Why can't I hear?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright.
I was pressing R.
Oh my god.
Please.
You're too fast.
My eyes are starting to water.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Please.
I'm just, please.
I'm in a... I'm in a wheelchair.
Please.
Please, sweetie, I'm in a wheelchair.
Please be gentle.
I'm in a wheelchair.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Oh my god.
Why can't I shoot my god?
We can still have a future together.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh my god, it's a fucking thumble whammy.
Guys, my eyes are so tight.
This, I'll just stab her myself.
I'm getting worse.
Oh my god, I was too fast.
My wheelchair didn't know how to drift.
But, oh, it just killed me.
I tipped over.
from my wheelchair and just end my existence.
A pool can't even get one hit.
I'll make it a second here from my eyes.
And here from my eyes.
My build is apt to dilute shit.
But I started on a wheelchair.
I die in a wheelchair.
As has been foretold.
Okay.
Someone said I could remove my chest.
What do I even?
Yeah.
Okay.
What chest do I use?
What a funny chest, which one's that?
Oh my god.
Something that doesn't weigh 10,000 pounds.
I don't know.
Alright.
Alba.
There we go.
Alright.
Here we go.
All right, here we go.
I start on the wheelchair.
I die in the wheelchair.
Nothing will stop me.
We can still do that.
Nobody said you can you leave me.
No, I told you to leave me.
Oh my gosh, she shoots me even when I'm slowly drifting in
the sky.
That's fucked, man.
Oh my god, I'm just face-taking everything.
You can tell.
You can tell I'm...
My soul can...
You can't...
No, guys, you don't understand.
She's my one.
It's so hard to shoot her She's my wife, guys I just, I just
can't, I can't just shoot her
She's been living, she's been doing my finances
You don't understand She was handling my finances guys
oh shit I actually pressed C oh my god I think I'm like I'm
devolving as a person a lot I've actually gotten worse as we
kept playing and I didn't think that was possible usually
players get better the longer you fucking bash your head
against the wall but for me I've actually gotten worse I...
Oh my god.
It's fine.
No.
I've actually gotten worse.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
It goes...
It flies around the building?
Guys, I'm locked out.
I'm locked out of the house.
I'm actually...
I'm just...
I'm just locked out.
Guys.
30%.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I actually got that.
Maybe.
I'm just hoping that I dodged it.
Oh, how does that hit me?
Oh!
Oh my god, please tell me I have my shield.
You don't have to do that, sweetie.
Woo!
For all the time!
Happy times we've had together!
You!
Dodge in your attacks a little to left, her middle house are
wide and void lot by dodging into- oh, I dodge into it.
That's a good advice.
That's a good advice Tom had to use that naked thing.
Okay.
Alright.
Have you tried?
This is Kampos Therapy.
Why do you think I'm letting her beat me up?
Oh my god, I tried dodging into it.
I don't think I did it correctly.
I thought...
I tried to face-tank even harder.
I don't know if it's working.
Guys, do you think I'm face-tanking a little?
hard or maybe I'm not face-tanking enough oh my god just in
case just in case oh my god oh my god holy shit
Where is she?
Where did she go?
Where did she go again?
Oh my god, I can't tell where she is.
My brothers and sisters.
Oh my god.
Humanity wants to burn it all.
Everything on Rupert.
Just in case, just in case I don't trust myself.
Oh my god!
Oh!
I did it!
Oh my god!
I fucking did it!
I didn't do any of your advice, but I did it!
I didn't learn anything, but I did it!
The wheelchair!
I suck.
Oh my god.
I fucking killed my wife.
Like at least I get to keep my dollar sign, dollar sign,
dollar sign.
No alibony.
The wife got, think about wife, the regret.
me walking into the boss fog for the hundred time having no
plan to change my strategy guys i told you my strategy works
guys i told you it works i told you i knew what i was doing
i just had to keep on doing it
you super chat thank you thank you all right you don't think
it was super chat that you think congrats on feeding your
wife i told you guys we live by the wheelchair we die by the
wheelchair show us that one guy that told me how to dodge it
and then i did not i absolutely did not do that
and i proceed to do none of that the corporations made a
joint announcement with the planetary
Rubicon was to be abandoned left a dead planet forever
meanwhile the monster who burned the stars vanished into the
flames never to be heard from again thanks for you now
continue to do the exact now continue to the same strat I
was doing the last ten attempts The fires of Rape.
What happened to me?
What about me?
Me?
The monster?
Wait!
Why am I the villain?
I saved the world!
But I saved the world!
I did it!
I saved the world!
Look, if I blew up the world, and then I saved everybody.
Because then we all, you know, I ended everyone's suffering.
So I'm a hero.
I saved them all.
I ended everyone's suffering.
You're not Stokey.
Destroy the world and the Solar System.
At least you kept the gas.
Yay!
Nobody gets my money.
Thank you, the Super Chat.
First, Kie-Husky.
Thank you, thank you.
Dual, thank you, Super Chat.
It turns out blowing up an entire Solar System while you're
still inside of it is a bad idea.
Thank you, the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
pointing in the super chat they could thank you the fires of
dealkeeper did it oh my god my eyes were actually she was
going so fast my eyes started watering there wait i didn't
get paid excuse well i guess like keeping my not having my
wife take 50 my income is considered winning i guess and
they're watching for more but you're playing so bad so i had
to say something top hat thank you with a super chat thank
you thank you but but i did it though i still won my strat
still worked it still worked though it might be a bad not
wait a strat can be bad if i beat the game with it
It can't be a bad strategy if I beat the game.
Think about that.
It is viable.
It's a viable strat.
Oh my gosh.
I know business.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh God.
Do you have any?
idea how much trouble you're in.
This whole entire planet and its inhabitant is the worst
possible crime.
You can't arrest me if everybody's dead.
Checkmate.
That's right.
Can't go to jail if there's no jail.
If the world's gone.
That's pure anarchy.
Yeah, can it also because I'm dead.
You can't arrest me.
I'm already dead.
Logical.
Thinking of the Super Chat, thinking, thank you.
I made one final boom.
One last boom to end it all.
I started with a big boom.
I ended with a very, very, very big boom.
Dress, thinking of the Super Chat, thinking thank you.
All strats can be good, but some can be better than others.
Yeah, my strat.
Star Force, thinking of the Super Chat, Thank you, thank
you.
No one can take your house.
You blow everything up.
Can't get a divorce if she's dead.
I don't think it was super chat.
Thank you.
Wife, big boom.
Wife, God.
Regret.
Till death do us part.
That's what it meant.
You can't divorce me.
It's till death do us part.
Someone has to die.
why do
the vows if we're not gonna honor it top hat thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you thank you uh great thank
you the super chat thank you thank you this is important to
get the other addings you have to choose the options you
didn't pick i don't have to play like this okay luckily the
great thing about me being a streamer is that you guys can
tell me what are the options i did I do not remember.
This took me like two months to finish, guys, with
everything going on.
I legitimately do not remember what were my original
choices, guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Arca, thank you for the super chat.
Well, now that Armor Core 6 is done.
Ace Combat 6 when.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
combat before uh so um so i would love to try it out for the
first time i don't know i guess like is combat six is the
only one that's on scene right people were telling me that
like i keep my build so i could just like so i can just like
speed run the other playthroughs but i don't know how fast
that's gonna be i mean if i just roll in with my wheelchair
it should be all right right i don't first try those other
bosses that all of you guys were like well i don't know if i
can do that again
i i don't know if i can first try those bosses again i it
goes by real fast oh okay and that's fine oh that's true
that's true i do got my big booms my big piler bunker always
at different bosses this time it's way faster I want I'll do
it like after my vacation I just wanted to focus on beating
getting the first ending today and then uh
um so so we'll see we'll see after the vacation today we're
just today we just focus on getting that win Getting that
first ending.
That was today's goal.
Might we see another route ending for...
We'll see how...
I'll try to do a long stream for the next armor core part.
Just so we can get through it.
You know?
So...
I don't know how long it's going to take me, though.
But I'll do a longer stream for when I'm back from vacation.
But that was fun, though.
I had a great time.
I had a great time in the wheelchair build.
I'm pretty sure my build was the shittiest build anyone has
ever done.
Well, not really.
I know people have done worse, but like, I...
Unintentionally, but also a choice at the same time.
I was very unoptimized.
It was definitely a very unoptimized build.
I did it!
i made a very silly one i just love the big booms and i'm
grateful to
you oh don't
tell me i have one last job walter don't you dare he's like
we have one welcome to the afterlife raven we have one last
job for you oh thank god at least he's proud of me i need
two last jobs yeah different lake type for a new playthrough
oh but like wheelchair's been with me for the thick and i'll
think about it in the vacation i'll i'll think about it guys
it's just wheelchair and big boom it was like a match made
in heaven
be better than that.
What, Batoki, what if a bigger wheelchair?
Call sign, Raven.
Authentication complete.
Removing MIA status.
Restoring access privileges.
This is all mine.
The mercenary support system.
Hello.
Raven, you've returned.
I have.
Welcome back.
All mind anticipates great things from you.
I'm back.
Did he back me up too?
Oh, wait.
I'm all the way back.
It's rewind time.
Yeah, all mine knows.
I've picked up some work for you already.
Take a look, 621.
Hey, buy my merch.
Oh, so everyone...
Oh, she knows we rewind the time.
Yeah, it's dokey dokey rewind time.
We have one last job, guys.
But I'm gonna, I'm gonna call it here.
We got our first ending.
We'll do our other endings when I'm back from vacation.
But, of course, at a great time.
I thought I had longer, I thought I had a longer session.
I'm not gonna lie.
I thought the ending was gonna take me even longer to do.
I think I could have actually gotten the ending last
playthrough.
But everyone was saying it's gonna take me a really, really
long time.
I mean, it did take me two hours, but I still think I could
have done that last playthrough.
Like just push through it.
But I'm gonna start my vacation after the stream.
And thank you all for watching, guys.
I hope you had a good day.
Great time.
Hang out with me.
And I hope you had a great time.
Watch me bash my head against the wall until the wall
started to crumble.
Always a great time.
And it was, I enjoyed my, I can't believe I started with the
wheel.
Well, I didn't start with a wheelchair, but that's what I
knew that build was for me.
I live with the wheelchair.
I died with the wheelchair.
It's the only way for the big booms.
Next thing, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Have fun on vacation.
Thank you.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I might, I don't know if I want to give up the big boom
life, but we'll see.
Maybe I'll change the legs because it's like, what can be
better than big boom?
I don't, I don't know.
Yeah, I broke my legs for this ride.
Everyone's like, please, Doki, change legs.
He's like, what do you want a Christmas miracle?
I'll just start walking again Like It's called Immersion,
guys You know, a guy doesn't suddenly walk After being
paralyzed Like
So, well, I don't know If I want to give up the big boom
Life But we'll see Well, after vacation, I'll think about it
During vacation, yeah
do you want to go fast oh my god faster than everyone is it
my turn to go fast you change the wheelchair to another
wheelchair um but anyway guys i'm gonna call here everyone
thank you again for hanging out with me thank you again for
um spending time with me i'm and even though i was late
thank you for waiting for the stream i really really
appreciate it guys um i always love hanging out with my
dragons and i'm gonna miss you guys while i'm on vacation
but i'm gonna have some videos uploaded um for those but
it's gonna be just for my vods like just videos that were um
just edited forms of the videos uh from the streams i've
done before in the past but you guys won't like you know
just uh relive those streams or we'll have some videos
uploaded during the time i'm gone i'll be back on the
seventh with a sponsor with snuffy a sponsor collab with
snuffy uh on twitch it will be on twitch i'll give you guys
a warning right now um if you guys follow me on twitter i'll
tweet about it there anyway guys um i was thinking about
streaming a bit longer but i figured like it makes more
sense to start the new part uh start the new part of the
stream with a new playthrough.
I don't want to like, I feel like it's, it, it, it makes
more sense to end the stream, um, with finishing the first
ending.
Anyway, guys, because I feel like I'll come back and be
like, where am I?
You know, I'm gonna come back from vacation.
I'm like, guys, I don't remember where I'm at again.
It's like, I have dementia, and I'm like, hello.
Why am I in the Warfield.
I was in the market just five minutes ago.
Anyway, as always, everybody, say hi, Dwayne, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
If you, except for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.